[Musik]
dabei ist luca und herzlich willkommen
hier heute zu einem neuen blog so was
auch sonst wir befinden uns hier noch
immer meine damen und herren also dahin
julia und ich sind hier noch an der
nordsee allerdings wird sich das heute
ändern
wir fahren heute nämlich zurück nach
köln kennt ihr diese teile eigentlich
gibt's im video wie das bei seinen
kunden machen
mir geht holen wir und der brötchen und
machen und weil wir die milliarden auf
gleich könnt ihr euch in einen der
letzten blocks erinnern wo ich beim
friseur war bei verhalten im guten
kollegen von mir
er hat weiß dass wir beiden hier an der
nordsee sind und meinte wir sollten ihm
eine postkarte machen
und jetzt mache spiel ist selbst eine
das ist jetzt unsere fertige postkarte
freunde sehen wir nicht toll aus geil
alter drei flaschen auf einem video
merci für diesen job luca das leichter
trotzdem ein supermarkt extra brötchen
kaufen um dann burger essen zu gehen
ich bin auch so cool wie es alter sachen
gepackt und sie jetzt auf schiffen haben
wir euch ja gesagt dass sie heute wieder
zurück nach hause sagt dass nur das
ganze schiff ist voll und wir sind jetzt
hier im eingangsbereich auf dem boden da
sollten wir im nächsten frühjahr kommen
weil ich so ein foto machen
red
draußen sitzen und däumchen drehen
arbeitet jule dann ihre fluglizenz alter
was für eine nette geste von dem bus
dass er noch auf diese passagiere war es
gerade gesehen hat mit orchestern
angekommen bei den damen sind nicht mehr
mit schiffen das wasser jetzt gerade
anfahren also wir warten jetzt auf taxi
fahren zu meinem auto und fahren dann
zurück in köln sind gerade 37 grad und
darauf habe ich gar keinen bock in köln
welche brink wieder auf ein paar videos
von euch reagieren
also es wird nachher noch kommen ich bin
schon einige male im auto erkannt wenn
ich irgendwie in großstädten haben
gestand oder irgendwie sowas aber dass
ich auf der autobahn junge soll mir
vorbei fährt im auto und ein massives
der x6 wieder in köln angekommen ich
glaube dem ort wo dicke leute und jetzt
sind wir auch wieder zurück in meiner
wohnung angekommen hier in köln meine
damen und herren
juli bereitet jetzt gerade noch so ein
kleines abendessen vorne der
zwischenzeit habe ich mir gedacht wie
ich in diesem blog auch schon gesagt
habe dass ich mal wieder auf einige
videos von euch reagieren werde ich weiß
dass sie alle ziemlich dumm sein
allerdings bin ich immer noch der
dümmste fall vergessen die schuhe hier
einzustellen hat sich gefahren wenn
diese schuhe sollten nicht in der sonne
so ein bisschen trocknen aber da standen
die jetzt eine woche ich werde jetzt auf
jeden fall nach unten in meinen auch mal
gehen und auch einige dumme videos von
euch reagieren denn die solltet ihr mehr
einsenden
[Applaus]
wow
irgendwie saß ich schon recht lange
nicht mehr in dieser position allerdings
würde ich sagen fangen wir direkt an mit
dem ersten video was mir ein gesendet
wurde es war ja wir schauen uns erst mal
an
denkst du rauchen ist cool die flashmobs
google talk leute greift nie zu drogen
greifen die zu alkohol greifen zur
zigarette greift nie zu irgendwas was
euch schaden könnte immer hausaufgaben
machen als apfel essen und erinnert
nicht so wie wenn das so ist dann genau
hierhin ich gehöre genau hierhin unter
seinen fuß sehe ich genauso
meine damen und herren sehen wir den
neuesten fitness youtuber am deutschen
youtube sternenhimmel mehr trainiert
seine füße hat das video geht noch ein
bisschen länger willst mich verarschen
ich weiß nicht ob ich das ganze
irgendwie gerade falsch beurteilt habe
ich das ganze fall schwer aber sitzt
dieses mädchen hier im pool
also ich meine erleiden im pool zu
sitzen ist nicht schlimm oder so aber
mit klamotten auf einem campingstuhl im
pool
im studio und pool hat sich geräumt
alter wunsch diese personen also dieses
mädchen
der grund warum ich luca reagiert echt
so lange nicht hochgeladen habe ich
bekomme albträume von euch locker lassen
uns einen spiel spielen baualter ich
berichte gerade von meinen alpträumen
und dann kommt das moorhuhn um die ecke
geschossen aber okay hofer hunde spiel
zusammen ein spiel zuerst suchst du dir
eine karte aus
ich soll mir eine karte aussuchen
[Musik]
ja wie soll ich jetzt eine auswählen ich
würde sagen ich nehme die karte unten
rechts einfach mal so ich hoffe du hast
eine ausgewählt
unten rechts das habe ich gerade schon
gesagt hier guck das war auf deiner
karte drauf ich glaube das ist ein
zeichen
dieses huhn
komplett bescheuert aber meine damen und
herren der luca shop ist natürlich der
beste job der welt ihr könnt euch ja
gerne mal ein bisschen umschauen die
top-adresse müssen wir glaube ich alle
mittlerweile kämen rede gerade noch von
meinem shop und angeben die hier in
einer katze mein sticker und die katze
reagiert nur so cool katze das ist der
grund warum ich liebe hunde mag hier
allerdings anhand meiner wange hier
sehen könnt und anhand eines abends hier
vorne ja auch hunde können manchmal böse
sein
[Musik]
das ist falsch mit dir wo ich kann ich
das ganze noch mal nachmachen
ja das war super nachgemacht luca
wieso können dass alle können das ich
verstehe diese leute aber auch nicht
voll viele können das irgendwie so lee
[Musik]
so tritt wieder das volk ich sehe schon
die ganzen instagram screenshots wieder
warum denkt man sich bei diesem video
kommt das schicke ich lukas wird ins
video ok wahrscheinlich denkt man sich
das weiß auch tatsächlich ins video
gekommen bis ihr freunde so zuschauer
von anderen youtuber die sitzen dann zu
hause machen gegen die ihre hausaufgaben
die geht raus ins gym die machen sport
die machen die ski waren das und dann
gibt's da die luke ru
wir haben halt irgendwie gefühlt zehn
räder ab vom wagen
apropos dummheit meiner community mal
der damen und herren bei der nächsten
video einsendungen hat mir ein junger
zuschauer einmal der community bewiesen
dass er ein mittel gegen diese trasse
hitze derzeit gefunden hat also ich
würde sagen film ab für diesen tipp
gegen den sommer
das war da
applaus hallo mein name ist luca hier
ist bedrückt nein hier ist luca di luca
das essen das schon wieder soll ich das
jetzt auch mal nachmachen hallo mein
name ist lokal hinein hier ist luca
[Musik]
hätte jetzt luca wieder wundervoll
nachgemacht luca schauspielschule wartet
auf jeden fall
ich weiß nicht wie viele texte dafür
wahrscheinlich eine chance
ich denke halt echt
ich glaube niemand aus meiner community
kann irgendwas ich aber auch nicht nicht
mal den mülleimer
heime
die kann nicht mehr den mülheimer
treffen und ich kann nicht mal reden
allerdings meine damen und herren würde
ich sagen kommen wir jetzt zum letzten
video was mir zu gesendet wurde es ist
ein video wo wirklich in dem schmied
drinstand hey luca wir haben die neue
bmw funktion hier am start und möchte
die mal sehen und ich weiß nicht ob
diese leute wirklich bei bmw arbeiten
oder ob sie einfach nur irgendwie tester
sondern da der vater dieses neue bmw
produkt halt irgendwie entwickelt hat
aber ich würde sagen meine damen und
herren ich halte euch nicht weiter aber
davon ab dieses video anzuschauen jetzt
ach du scheiße so sieht mein
schreibtisch noch relativ normal aus
aber von unten sieht eher so aus
naja wir schauen uns mal das video von
der neuen bmw funktion an
lustig durch michaela klasse freut mich
echt klasse sogar ich repariere mal kurz
mein schreibtisch an der stelle durch
den heutigen doch jetzt allerdings auch
bedeuten dass wir gefahr dass wir das
gerne mal einen daumen hoch das gerne
mal einen daumen hoch darf freunde aber
im nächsten blog ich werde schon mal
sagen werde ich das erste mal mit jule
minecraft spielen beziehungsweise jude
spielt das erste mal minecraft ich bin
ja der profi in diesem spiel das heißt
sie werden sehen wie jude ist nicht da
schlagen wie es die sammlung auf einem
kanal kommen also wenn ihr noch kein
abonnent hat freunde und meinen kanal
aber nie findet zeit lafarge und saint
vil
lassen ich will ihn beenden
[Musik]